Aleister Crowley may just be one of the
most interesting men who ever lived he
was a self-proclaimed magician scholar
writer and even an undercover spy he was
known as the great beast 666 because
some believed that he was the Antichrist
written about in the book of Revelation
others believed that he was a genius and
a visionary and that the world would not
be the same if it wasn't for his
teachings well today we're gonna talk
about the life of this legendary figure
and you yourself can decide if he truly
was the wickedest man alive
in 1875 Aleister Crowley was born in
Warwickshire England to two extremely
religious parents his grandfather had a
successful distillery business and yet
his father never wanted to spend any of
the money because he believed
drunkenness was a sin he became a
preacher instead and passionately
evangelized the teachings of a
fundamentalist Christian group called
the Plymouth Brethren they taught young
Edward to live life as simply as
possible and that men they only existed
in order to serve God
any form of excess whether it was
spending money dressing in nice clothes
or eating more than was absolutely
necessary was considered a sin and the
temptation to indulge in anything was
seen as the work of the devil when he
was very young
Edward looked up to his father and
wanted to become a preacher just like
him he obeyed his parents every demand
and instead of going outside to play
with the other children he instead
studied the Bible as you might imagine
this did not make him very popular boy
in school and he was bullied mercilessly
by the other children his father he died
of tongue cancer when he was only 11 and
he was left in the care of his
overzealous mother living under such
harsh conditions on a daily basis made
Edward very sick the doctors said that
he was so weak he would die within just
a few months if no changes were made
thankfully his uncle stepped in and
suggested that maybe the boy needed to
live in the countryside Edward moved in
with his uncle and began mountain
climbing and running through the forest
where he breathed fresh air
his uncle allowed him to have fun which
was a concept that had been completely
foreign to him up until that point they
even brought him to pubs and let him
drink underage and pay for a prostitute
so that he could lose his virginity at
the age of 15
after all the doctors said that he might
die soon so his uncle wanted him to
experience as much fun as possible with
the time he had left his health though
it fully recovered him he was sent back
to live with his mother but Deadwood had
changed in his time away and he was now
in full-blown teenage rebellion he knew
that the Plymouth Brethren were to blame
for his sickly childhood and he rejected
all of their religious teachings he no
longer wanted to be a preacher and he
wanted the free will to make his own
life choices he hated the idea that
nearly everything that made people happy
was considered to be a
sinn his mother was shocked that her
obedient son had changed so much in his
time away and said that he'd become the
Beast from the book of Revelation after
arguing with her he decided that if he
needed to commune with the devil in
order to live his life according to his
own rules or so be it he would become
the Beast that his mother said he was
one of the first wicked things he did
was have sex with the maid on his
mother's bed just to spite her when she
found out she fired the maid immediately
in the poor girl's reputation was ruined
to the point where she could no longer
work the maid was forced into
prostitution and Crowley claimed that
she became Jack the Ripper's first
victim he even said that he knew the
Ripper personally ins that he was an
occultist later he would write about his
formative years I was in the death
struggle with self Gordon Satan fought
for my soul those long three hours God
conquered now I have only one doubt left
which of the Twain was God
when Crowley graduated high school he
was sent away to Cambridge where he
introduced himself to his new classmates
as Aleister Crowley he joined the Chess
Club and was able to win several
competitions in 1898 when Aleister was
22 years old he fell in love with a
fellow classmate Herbert Jerome Paulette
very few people in the school knew that
Herbert had an alter ego dressing in
drag in private night clubs is Diane de
Rugy crowley wrote a love poems about
Herbert and they are filled with anguish
about his wish to be with him clearly
his bisexuality was even more motivation
to reject Christianity in the eyes of
the church his love for Herbert was
considered to be an abomination after
graduating from University Aleister
inherited the Crowley family fortune and
he could finally do whatever he wanted
he began to hire female prostitutes
nearly every day and he bought books on
the occult he was writing dirty poetry
and publishing them overseas under a pen
name when he was in his early 20s he
found out that he was not alone in his
fascination with the occult and the
possibility that magic could be real he
joined a group of aspiring wizards
called the order of the Golden Dawn
which had famous members like poet
William Butler Yeats and Bram Stoker the
author of Dracula they claimed that
their translated ancient Egyptian texts
sold grimoires filled with ancient
spells and Jewish mysticism from the
Kabbalah
they believed that they could perform
real magic communicate with angels and
get to know their inner soul when he
showed up to his first meeting of the
order of the Golden Dawn Crowley was
wearing a disguise and introduced
himself as Count of Vladimir far off' he
was still afraid that his family would
find out that he was dabbling in the
occult since he did not want to ruin his
reputation
no one was convinced of his costume
there because he was a baby-faced youth
wearing a false moustache and speaking
in a terrible Russian accent later on in
life Aleister Crowley actually became a
secret agent for the British government
during World War one because he claimed
that he had successfully infiltrated a
secret society now technically that's
true but the result of his spy career
was probably more along the lines of the
Pink Panther rather than James Bond
after he felt comfortable knowing that
the Golden Dawn took privacy very
seriously
Crowley admitted to his true identity
unfortunately it already started things
off on the wrong foot and some people in
the group found it hard
despite this initial deception Crowley
took their teachings very seriously and
he was able to quickly move on through
the lessons the golden dawn wanted its
new members to be able to get in touch
with their inner soul before they were
taught real magic
this was accomplished through a lot of
discussions of philosophy yoga
meditation and mantras they would write
down their dreams in daily journals and
interpret what they meant about their
inner selves however there were some
spells that they performed on a daily
basis because they truly believed that
they could summon angels to their aid
the lesser banishing ritual of the
pentagram goes like this in the name of
God's the God of Israel may Michael be
at my right hands Gabriel at my left
Uriel before me Raphael behinds me and
above my head the presence of God
Crowley believes so strongly in the
supernatural that he claimed that these
were the early stages of a magical
journey which would get him in touch
with his guardian angel he openly talked
about his desire to call upon demons and
the ancient gods he incorporated
psychedelic drugs into his routines
because he believed that it intensified
his spiritual experiences this was all
genuinely concerning to the rest of the
Golden Dawn many of them were
teetotaling aristocrats who felt that
his ideas were radical if not downright
terrifying the members did not want
Crowley to rise in the ranks of the
society because he was clearly
interested in black magic and they
believed that he would use his powers
for evil
there was a strict rule that no one
could pay one another to teach the magic
but he managed to convince one of the
members to teach him higher levels of
spells in exchange for free rent in his
books Aleister Crowley casually mentions
walking Eliezer inmate as he was
levitating as if this was totally normal
among the members of the Golden Dawn in
1899 when he was just 24 years old
Aleister Crowley bought a mansion on the
shores of Loch Ness in Scotland called a
ball skiing house just so he could
perform a spell called the Abra Mellon
ceremony however nothing actually
happened he never saw any angels or
demons no matter how hard he tried
apparently he grew tired of doing this
ritual every single day without seeing
any result so he wandered off to do
something else
rumors spread that since he failed to
finish the ceremony this unlocked the
gates of hell years later Jimmy Page
that lead guitarist of Led Zeppelin
purchased Crowley's home on Loch Ness he
claims that the house was truly haunted
by crevice demons aleister crowley's
first wife was a woman named Rose Edith
Kelly when they met she was a young
widow who was engaged to a man that her
parents chose for her
Crowley convinced her to elope with him
instead so after only knowing each other
for just one day so that he could
prevent her from entering into this
arranged marriage they ran away on a
spur-of-the-moment honeymoon to Egypt
together
Crowley brought Rose into a dark cave
and began reciting his spells he was
reading from a book called Goethe the
Lesser Key of Solomon the idea was that
he would summon an Egyptian god Horus he
went through his chance when roses had
suddenly fell back she claims that in
that moment she had a vision and heard
the voice of Horus Crowley was
frustrated with Rose assuming that she
was playing a prank on him he had been
studying the occult and attempting to
summon demons and gods for years and
they never appeared to him in any
visions he simply couldn't believe that
it was possible for Rose to evoke Horus
when she wasn't even trying but she kept
insisting that she truly did see
something in the caves and that the gods
had been angry with him up until that
points because of his arrogance still
not believing her and Aleister took her
to one of the museums and asked her to
point out the God she saw Rose walked
right up to the correct image of Horus
exhibit number 666 after seeing this
proof they rushed back to their
apartment in Cairo so that they could
talk about the visions in private Rose
said that Horus had given her
instructions on how to communicate with
the spirits she gave Aleister a
spiritual ritual to perform when he was
done he heard a whisper over his
shoulder from the voice of his guardian
angel iowa's the angel instructed him to
write down lots of information over the
course of three days and he published
this in a text called the book of the
law though his famous quote was do what
thou wilt shall be the whole of the law
basically this means do whatever you
want with your own life Crowley it was
thrilled with this revelation and when
he returns England he told all of his
friends in the Golden Dawn about the
voices that he and Rose had hurt in
Egypt many were reluctant to believe him
and some were angry believing that he
had been tricked and who actually
communicating with a demon instead of a
guardian angel at this point they were
still refusing to allow Crowley to
graduate to the next level of the secret
society so he visited the leader of the
Paris
chapter of the Golden Dawn MacGregor
Malthus he explains the situation back
in London and Malthus seemed to agree
that Crowley deserved n to the next
level when he returned to London with
his certificate from Malthus in hand the
other members they still wouldn't accept
him so he snuck into the clubhouse and
he changed the locks the next day he
laughed at the men as they failed to get
inside not surprisingly he was then
officially kicked out of the Golden Dawn
a year later in 1905 Aleister Crowley
took Gruber his friends climbing on
kanchenjungha which is one of the
largest and most treacherous mountains
in the world they got to 25,000 feet but
one of the men on the expedition a
photographer named Jules Jaco Guillermo
was angry at how Crowley was treating
everyone else on the crew and he wanted
to take over the expedition the
expedition was marred by arguments
between Crowley and the others who
thought that he was reckless
they eventually mutant it against
Crowley's control with the other
climbers heading back down the mountain
as nightfall approached despite
Crowley's warnings that it was too
dangerous subsequently several porters
were killed in an accident something for
which Crowley was widely blamed for in
the mountaineering community it was
claimed that Crowley sat inside of his
tent and trying to someone a demon at
that very moment an avalanche came down
the mountain they screamed for help but
Crowley ignored them and he left them
for dead he later wrote that he had
absolutely no sympathy for the
unfortunate accident even though many of
the men miraculously survived
aleister crowley's marriage with rose it
fell apart after the death of their
first daughter when she was only two
years old even though they had a second
daughter together named Lola Zaza it was
clear that they were no longer in love
and Rose fell into a deep depression
they got a divorce in 1909 based on his
own adultery in just two years later he
had to put her in an asylum for having
neurological damage from her alcoholism
this tended to be a trend because most
of the people who've even attempted to
have a personal relationship with
Crowley ended up having their lives
completely ruined it's sort of a chicken
or egg scenario did his belief in the
occult attract mentally unstable people
into his life or was his wickedness
enough to drive people insane Carly was
not very interested in being a father so
he left his daughter in the care of
boarding schools and nannies he started
his own cult called thelema where he
torched the book of the law like it was
the Bible he started a commune in a
villa in Italy that he called the abbey
of Thelema everyone who lived there was
encouraged to do whatever they wanted
whenever they want it they took drugs
they had orgies together and children
were running around the grounds naked
one of the rooms in the villa was called
the nightmare room where Crowley painted
terrifying pictures on the walls he
encouraged his followers to take LSD and
stare at the frightening images until
they completely lost fear of anything
the neighbors were shocked and even to
this very day the locals say that the
place is haunted by a curse rumor has it
that the rituals became more and more
intense to the point where they even
participated in bestiality and animal
sacrifice one of ours as lovers a woman
named lair has a nervous breakdown after
this and she went straight to the
British press after she stated the one
of the followers died after drinking the
blood of a cat the Italian authorities
they came in and forced the group out of
the house and banned them from ever
returning the abbey of Thelema is still
abandoned to this very day and as we
said people believe it's haunted
Aleister Crowley he visited the United
States to spread his message and he
inspired several people to practice the
occult as well including rocket
scientist Jack Parsons and the founder
of Scientology l ron Hubbard he taught
them how to perform sex magic which was
the belief that in the moment of orgasm
their intentions could be heard by the
universe
unfortunately for Crowley all of the
drugs and sex eventually caught up with
him he became a full-on heroin addict
since he lost it from men
mount of weight in the 1930s a
journalist labeled Aleister Crowley as a
black magician after years of running
cults and buying properties all over the
world his inheritance it had finally run
dry he was living alone in a boarding
house doing whatever he could to get his
fix and stay alive he decided to sue the
journalist for libel even though he had
called himself a magician and the beast
in his own books he lost the case of
course and he had to endure a public
humiliation many people never saw him in
London again so they spread a rumor that
he had died from a drug overdose all
alone in his boarding house they felt
that this would be a fitting end to such
a wicked man but in reality fate gave
him a second chance at life a young
woman named Deirdre McClelland
approached Aleister Crowley after the
trial was over she said that she had
read all of his books and was a huge fan
and she wanted to have a child now this
level of RAD Mauritian pretty much
creepy enough for most celebrities to
run in the opposite direction but
Aleister Crowley he was so desperate
that he agreed to go home with the
stranger McClelland helps him get clean
from drugs and she stayed with him
through the worst of his withdrawal
after he was healthy again they had a
son together who was named Alister at
attack
Crowley little Alastair was Crowley's
pride and joy and he felt a lot of
regret for the way that it acted in his
younger years after living his entire
life trying to prove that people should
be as selfish as they could possibly be
he finally realized that true happiness
and fulfilment they came from family
they lived in a house in Cornwall where
they spent their summers on the beach
according to Deirdre McClelland Aleister
Crowley slipped into a coma just before
he died the sky lit up in a cacophony of
thunders the gods came to reclaim his
soul he died in 1947 at 72 years old in
reality he died of chronic bronchitis
aggravated by pleurisy and myocardial
degeneration his funeral was held at
Brighton crematorium and about a dozen
people attended and Lewis work insin
read excerpts from the Gnostic Mass the
book of the law and him de panne the
funeral generated controversy and was
labeled a black mass by the tabloids
years after his death artists and
musicians more over the world started to
read Aleister Crowley's work and it
inspired them to live their lives in the
way that they wanted hippies based their
free love movement on his writings and
even John Lennon
sidered him to be a hero putting him on
the cover of Sgt pepper's Lonely Hearts
Club his motto of do what thou wilt was
inscribed on the vinyl of Led Zeppelin's
album Led Zeppelin 3 David Bowie made
reference to Crowley and the lyrics of a
song quicksand his life was filled with
outrageous claims and without his
attempts to shake up proper Victorian
society the world we live in today just
may not have been the same without
Aleister Crowley
so I sure hope you found that video
interesting bit of a bizarre one I know
if you did like it give us a thumbs up
also subscribe
we've got other videos just like this I
think we're doing three or four a week
now so if you subscribe you'll get all
of those hit that notification bell so
you do actually find out about them if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now they I've got another
channel called highlight history you'll
find a link to that below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]